i heard you're drinking coffee now for
the first time in your life
yeah it's incredible i mean i i i never
understood it before and now i totally
like i and i haven't had a coffee yet
but and honestly all i'm thinking about
during this interview is
when is this done so i can go get my
it's other than seeing my son in the
morning i it's the main thing i look
forward to
it it's addictive isn't it oh it's a
drug i don't know why we don't just
like it's really fascinating like how
why is society just decided
oh you know what this drug is okay this
is fine yeah sure it's no problem
i mean you're sitting and talking to me
and you're dreaming about a cup of
coffee
i mean this is what's going on now i
mean the whole purpose i don't like the
taste of it but i just like what it does
to my brain
it like snaps it into focus what coffee
are you having see i don't know anything
about it so
i just i go i ask for a black i just
black iced coffee
um oh that's it that's well so and it
could be anything
but but so it was funny so i was all
alone up into cnn
uh when i started drinking coffee and i
i was like you know what i wanted
there i think they have coffee machines
in this building so i went
to like the communal kitchen area which
is you know there's no one else there
and they had this fancy coffee machine
and i took out there all these different
packets of coffee
and i spent a good 10 minutes trying to
rip off the
top oh no because i was like
how do you do work there and then i
suddenly realized oh no you just put
this in the machine and you close it
this machine is one of the greatest
inventions ever made
somehow it you just put this thing in
and it takes off this thing which i
could not rip off
no matter how hard i tried and and then
the coffee comes out and then that thing
disappears you don't even have to throw
it out
anderson i am admiring your this room
that you're in it looks
beautiful with you
i mean what a cat you are you've got a
great apartment
let me see if i can i don't know oh
gorgeous yeah
look oh i love this library yeah yeah
it's
uh so i live in an old firehouse and uh
i wanted the whole thing to be like a
cabinet of curiosities like the home of
an explorer
from the late 1800s who had like come
back and
lives in this house full of all the
stuff that they've collected over the
years